Turnover and triage in Ukraine today.
The shakeup at the top of Ukraine's
military ranks.
President
Zelensky dismissing
the commander of joint force
operations Mr.
Zelensky did not explain why or why now,
as this leadership shuffle
collides with a new Russian
offensive overnight.
A staggered drone assault.
14 Iranian
made unmanned attack
aircraft buzzing over Kiev.
Ukrainian air
defenses say they shot down
11 of those drones
in Ukraine,
south and east Moscow
trying to fracture the line.
Russia launching 81 artillery strikes
over the last 24 hours.
Russia hopes the bombing
frenzy chokes off
Ukrainian forces
in and around block mount
and breaks a battlefield stalemate.
Let's begin in eastern Ukraine with CNN's
Alex Marquardt with the latest
from the battlefield.
Alex,
Well, John, absolutely right.
A pivotal moment in this fight
and as we focus
on the fighting in the east.
We have also been reminded that
Russia continues to try to bomb
cities all across Ukraine with drones.
Overnight,
at least two people
killed in the city of criminal Nowitzki,
that is in southwestern Ukraine.
Very far from the front line.
They were both
first responders
who were responding to an earlier
strike by a drone,
a so-called double tap attack.
Then there were some 11 drones
that were sent over Kiev.
Nine of those shot down.
They were sent in at least two waves.
And the air raid
sirens in Kiev
ringing out for some five
and a half hours.
A reminder that even as life continues
relatively normally
in many cities all across the country,
there is
the constant possibility
that those cities
may be attacked by drone.
But the fiercest fighting,
John, is taking place
in the eastern
part of the country,
particularly around the eastern city
of back.
It does appear that Russian forces,
primarily from the Volga mercenary
group, are making some progress.
They claim that they have
taken several villages
north of the city
as they try to encircle it.
Ukrainian forces say that they are
standing their ground,
that they are repelling attacks.
We have not heard
any talk from the highest levels
of the Ukrainian government
about surrendering this city.
But President Zelinsky
softening his tone on that, saying
that he will not defend it at all costs.
We're watching that very carefully.
At the same time
as this general
whose area of command
was much of the east, Major
General Edward Muscala
was dismissed by a presidential decree
with little explanation from presidents
once his office. John.
Alex Marquardt
live for us on the ground in Ukraine.
Alex, thanks for that update.
Let's get some important perspective
now from the former director
and deputy director
of National Intelligence, Beth Center.
Beth, to the point of this shakeup,
no explanation.
You relieved from duty,
a top official in the military command.
There has been a purge
an anti-corruption purge of late.
But no explanation here.
Does it come as a surprise?
What does it tell you
at a time when,
you know
Russia is picking up
the pace of its attacks?
Well, there
hasn't been much turnover
actually in the Ukrainian
command structure.
And so, you know,
I think these things happen.
It could be one of two things either.
It's part of the corruption probe
or its dissatisfaction
in some way
or inability to carry out the orders
or the offensive that's planned.
So we will find out soon
enough about that.
But I think that, you know,
making a hard decision in wartime,
it's actually may be a good sign.
And so you have over the weekend
something quite remarkable.
The CIA director publicly
talking about a warning to China,
talking about what his agency,
what the intelligence community
has learned about China.
Connect the dots for me.
You just heard in the lead up.
Iranian made drones over Kiev.
And now Bill
Burns, the CIA director, saying
we have intelligence and China
don't do it.
We're confident that
the Chinese leadership
is considering the provision
of lethal equipment.
We also don't see that
a final decision has been made yet.
It takes a process to even say
that some people would say, well,
he didn't say much.
But for the CIA director to say
that publicly takes a process.
Why this is part of a strategy.
It's like an actual policy and strategy
by this White House to use intelligence
to declassify it, to release it
publicly in order
to affect the decisions of adversaries.
So in this case, it's
designed to deter China.
It's also designed
to make sure
that the Europeans are onside
about the threat that China poses
and the threat
that China and Russia pose together.
So I think
it's going to be very effective
when Biden said this weekend.
Look,
I don't really think
that they're going to follow
through with this.
I agree with that,
because now that it's out there
and it's called,
it makes it really hard
for China to do this
because they need the U.S.
and Europe economically.
We have talked from the beginning
of the Ukraine conflict
not only about how this Putin process,
this and NATO's
resolve in the US was all,
but how does President Xi process this?
Nick Burns,
the ambassador to China, said
at an event earlier today
that he thinks
she is surprised
by the strength
of the world's democracies.
Is that right?
Yeah, I think so. I think so.
And I think that this is the reason
we've seen a shift in China's
approach toward the rest of the world.
Instead of the wolf warriors,
these diplomats
that go to European capitals
or in European capitals
and are really, really super tough.
Instead, we're seeing a charm offensive
trying to put things back together
because they need
that trade
as trying to try to recover
from the COVID crisis.
So the United States is publicly warning
China there will be consequences.
Don't do it.
Do not send
lethal weapons to Vladimir Putin.
One of the Chinese responses,
no one,
they say we weren't planning that, which,
you know,
just take that with a grain of salt,
I guess.
But number two,
they say, well, you're hypocrites.
You're sending weapons
into the battlefield.
One of the big questions right now
is, will will the West?
Will the United States or others
send fighter jets?
President Biden was asked about this on
Friday, and he says not now.
You don't think he needs F-16s now?
No, he doesn't need F-16s now.
There is no basis upon
which there is a rationale,
according to our military now,
to provide F-16s.
But you're not ruling it out?
I am really not for now.
Does that hold?
We have seen month by month
in this
now in its second year
beginning the second year
of the conflict, a change in U.S.
posture and NATO's posture,
other Western allies posture
about the
the muscular nature of the weapons
they will give.
Why no F-16s
So when Jake Sullivan and others
say that
they don't need the F-16s
now, that what they really need
is more artillery
and more of what we've been giving them.
I agree with that.
But I also agree with generals
who say the phrase is,
you have to be prepared
not just to fight the war of today,
but the war of tomorrow.
And this is where the critics,
I think are also right,
is you've got to put everything in place
to get those F-16s
there when you're ready to do so.
And so we talked a minute ago about China
and its local politics,
the internal politics.
What about Russian internal politics?
Vladimir Putin gives this interview
over the weekend.
Listen to this.
No one it's dated, if you will.
It's a fantasy of how the world is today.
But what does he mean by this
We cannot see.
They have
one goal
to break up the former
Soviet Union, in its main part,
the Russian Federation.
And then perhaps they will accept us
in the so-called family
of civilized peoples,
but only separately,
each part separately.
Moreover, in today's conditions,
when all the leading natal countries
have declared their main goal,
to inflict a strategic defeat on us
so that our people suffer,
how can we, under these conditions,
not take into account
their nuclear potentials
Two things jumped out at me.
You're way smarter than me
when it comes to how
he thinks, so help me.
Number one, the nuclear
potential nuclear potentials.
He waves that flag
when he feels it's in his interest
that, well, they have nuclear weapons
and they don't like us.
But they have one goal to break up.
The former
Soviet Union and its main
part of the Soviet
Union's been broken up for a long time,
at least to use the word former
what is he
what is he trying to communicate
to the people at home there?
He's trying to communicate
what the Russians
call strategic depth,
which means that he's got this
this alliance of former Soviet states,
including like Central Asia,
that he has under his thumb.
And he needs to keep those.
And right now, this week,
Secretary Blinken
is headed to Kazakhstan and Uzbekistan,
those core parts of this former
Soviet Union
that we're trying to break away.
So, yeah, it's kind of true,
but that doesn't mean that
that's not the way the world should work.